Speaker 1: related to all of this election,
misinformation, disinformation, propaganda.
Is this news that Dominion, the voting machine
company, is not only have they sued Mike Lyndell,
not only have they sued Rudy Giuliani, not
only have they sued Sidney Powell, they are
now suing Newsmax, O'Brien and Patrick Byrne,
who is the CEO of Overstock.com.
So someone who is fundamentally committed
to anti-democratic principles, Patrick Byrne,
owns a company out there that you may or may
not do business with and you may or may not
want to know or have that information.
Reading from The Insider, Dominion sues Newsmax
owned and Overstock CEO Patrick Byrne for
promoting election conspiracy theories.
Dominion Voting System sued Newsmax and one
American news network on Tuesday, accusing
the far right media organizations of defamation
for pushing far fetched conspiracy theories
that the election technology company rigged
the twenty twenty presidential election.
Republicans love corporate autonomy.
Republicans love to treat corporations like
people, so they have to be on board with this
lawsuit.
No.
Wouldn't you think Tuesday's lawsuit against
OCN accused it of engaging in a race to the
bottom with Fox and other outlets such as
Newsmax, to spread false and manufactured
stories about election fraud and, quote, Dominion
quickly became the focus of this downward
spiral of lies.
As each broadcaster attempted to outdo the
other by making the lies more outrageous,
spreading them further and endorsing them
as strongly as possible, the lawsuit said.
It added that although the lies promoted by
Ohayon were, quote, verifiably false, they
were still devastating to Dominion's reputation.
And this, on its face, seems logical.
It seems reasonable.
It seems like common sense that their reputation
would be impugned and their bottom line affected
by this.
They have to show damages because before the
2016 election, could you have named a voting
a company that ran voting machines?
I could not.
And it is because of that publicity is because
of that coverage, is because of these pernicious
and sinister conspiracy theories that we do
know their name.
This lawsuit does seem to have merit, Dominion
also accused Ohayon host Shanelle Reon, not
her real name, and Christina Bob of amplifying
and spreading false claims about Dominion.
The network deputized Riaan as an in-house
spokesperson for All Dominion related content.
The lawsuit said Dominion began in January
by suing Sidney Powell.
As I mentioned, Rudy Giuliani, who claimed
Dominion has secret ties to the regime of
now dead Venezuelan dictator Hugo Chavez and
develop technology that flipped votes from
then President Donald Trump to now President
Joe Biden.
Dominion, as an aside here, also sued my pillow
CEO, Mike Lyndell, who pushed versions of
that falsehood.
So Mike Pillow and all of this these this
cohort of dumb dumbs and purveyors of conspiracy
theories, they're all in the same camp and
they're all doing damage to the republic.
These are these are fake Dritz.
They claim to love the country.
They claim to cherish our freedoms.
They the they rattle on about the Constitution
of the United States and having taken an oath,
many of them, and they violate that oath,
they violate the the the possibility that
they have respect for democratic rule when
they are actively months after a free and
fair election, months after they are continuing
to spread gossip and misinformation, whipping
their their followers, their adherents into
a frenzy such that they attack the government,
such that there's a violent insurrection after
United States Capitol where people died.
Where they, like I said yesterday, erect a
hangman's Gallow chanting Hang Mike Pence.
Stalking throughout the Capitol grounds, Nancy
Pelosi.
Where are you?
Ominous, dangerous, un-American, anti-democratic.
And where is their leader to quell this?
Where is Donald Trump, who certainly not short
for words, he's not short on media appearances,
he could end this.
Just like he could have ended the pandemic
early on.
Instead, he so doubt about masks, Donald Trump
could go on Fox, he could make the rounds
to these idiot networks.
He could go on Fox News.
He could go on Newsmax.
He could go on one news and say, stop it,
everybody, we need to come together.
Insurrection and violent revolt against your
government isn't the way forward.
We will beat them at the ballot box next time.
But you know what?
Donald Trump doesn't have the mettle.
Donald Trump doesn't have it in himself to
do the right thing because the right thing
would mean taking a step back from the spotlight.
The right thing would mean not making it all
about Donald Trump.